[Music]
hello everybody and
welcome to my talk on voice
uh my name is meg rozoff and i'm an
american writer living in
london and i started writing quite
late in life and
once i started teaching creative writing
i realized that i couldn't teach people
to write but i could
teach them to at least try
uh to think properly or to think like a
writer and that's when i started to get
this idea about voice
now everybody talks about voice um but
it's very
difficult to actually define what it is
the first question that i usually ask
and the first question that i
asked myself uh when i first
started getting sent books by publishers
was why are so many books so
dead um i used to think that
in order to write a good book all you
had to do was have a good plot
and to be able to string a sentence
together so
i would pick up books that had been sent
to me by publishers and i would think
well yes i'll have a look at this
it's bound to be good i know the person
they're quite articulate or i don't know
the person but
you know it looks beautiful it's got a
good cover um
and time after time i found myself
feeling that there was
just something missing in the book
and i started thinking of them as zombie
books
now the thing that really does tend to
be missing in a voi
in a book is a strong voice
um the word is misleading
as i've written here uh voice suggests a
superficial quality
but it's not a superficial quality voice
is in fact the essence
of your personality it's the clearest
expression of your dna
plus a lifetime of experience so what is
the combination of nature
and nurture add up to in your head
what you're looking for is the one thing
that you can say
that nobody else can say um
i find this is something that uh that
people don't
really have an easy idea thinking about
you go to look at paintings in a gallery
for instance and you look at the mona
lisa and you feel nothing
now that's always blamed on you it's
your fault you can't somehow react to
the mona lisa
but maybe it's the mona lisa's fault
maybe lisa are not
compatible maybe the voice of that
artist
is not a voice that speaks to you
but as an artist what you need is to
have the voice in the first place so
that at least you're speaking to
somebody
now i started thinking about
the brain as a as a colander
and i started to think about how single
day
there will be a million experiences
more than a million a billion
experiences you wake up you open your
eyes you put your
feet on the floor you go you have
breakfast a billion million things
happen to you
and most of them just go straight
through the holes of the calendar
you'll never remember them if i asked
you what were you doing at 7 11 in the
morning
uh a week ago tuesday
chances are you wouldn't be able to tell
me um
but every once in a while and really
almost every once in a blue moon
something happens in your day in your
life
that gets stuck in the colander and
sticks there and may still be in that
colander
10 years later 20 years later 50 years
later
there's a question that therapists ask
when you go
in one of the first questions they ask
is what's your first memory
um and if you ask people that question
just routinely you get an extraordinary
variety
of of first memories my first memory i
was very very young and it was a dream
and it was a nightmare in fact
and if you dumped that colander with all
the things
that stuck in your head out onto a big
white table
at any age at age 11 or 18 or 35 or
60 you would notice that what's in your
colander
is completely different from what's in
the person's next to use calendar
because what's stuck in their brain
even if you had an identical upbringing
will not be
remotely the same and this is why the
writing of memoir is so difficult
because i was talking about this
um the other day um
because two people identical twins in a
family
will have completely different
experiences growing up
even if their dna is the same their what
they observe in life how they're reacted
to
uh by the parents by the other siblings
by
life will be completely different
now one thing i do think is quite
interesting is that
school um especially in this country in
in the uk
is really designed to
erase out um the individuality the
difference you know you're all passing
the same exams you're all wearing the
same uniforms
um and uh it's it's almost as if we have
to educate people
back into their idiosync their
idiosyncrasies
and uh their faults in a way you know
you
you're always told you have to be good
that you have to be you know
soft-spoken and polite and you know
honest and
fair dealing and you know ev
as if everyone should be the same and if
you happen to have an explosive
passionate
you know nutty personality um
it's often not valued as much or if
you're
not very outgoing it's often not valued
as much people are always saying
smile or you know why don't you talk up
more
uh but that's what you are that's what's
in your head and that's what you really
need to treasure above all things
so just imagine all these kinds of
things anybody who's a gardener out
there will recognize this
this is all the kind of stuff that's
collecting in your brain and it's
composting down into this really
rich dark uh material
let's call it material because when
you're writing a book uh that's where
the book comes from
another example is is the my my favorite
train example
and what i like to do if i've got a an
actual live audience in front of me is
to say we've got a
we've got a train that's half a mile
long and everybody
here today is sitting in the
this in the left hand window of the
train
you're all looking out at the same
landscape as it's passing by at speed
and every single person on that trip
will notice something different we'll
take away something different from that
trip so i always say that what i notice
is is animals i i'll be looking for
horses
uh out the window if i can't find a
horse you know uh
i would get special extra points for a
deer or if i were in america a moose
imagine seeing a moose out the window
um i'm always looking for hairs in
fields
which you can't see if you take a train
in march april you know you do often see
i once saw two boxing hairs in a field
and that made my
journey absolutely extraordinary um
you know somebody else might be looking
at thinking about property
you know looking at the houses that you
pass and saying well i'd quite like to
live there or
i'd really like to have a garden like
that um
you know someone else might be looking
at trees or looking for birds or
not looking at all uh looking down at
the book in their lap
or you know at the person sitting across
from them on the aisle
but basically everyone's sitting in the
same place on the same
journey it's going to have a different
experience and the
quality the the difference between your
experience and the experience of the
person
next to you or the other people in your
life is what's going to make your story
interesting
now if you don't know what's in your
calendar if you don't know what's in
your
head you need to find out um
i was just reading this over this
morning
and i thought well that's interesting
the interpretation of dreams is the
royal road to a knowledge of the
unconscious activities of the mind well
it must have been freud who said that
um dreams are one of the best ways to
get
into your unconscious mind because it's
the one place where
the the the deep dark unconscious
pokes its way up to the surface so
if you think about it and a lot of
people haven't ever thought about it
if you think about it the idea that you
go to sleep and you shut off your
conscious mind uh and some of your brain
is telling you stories and it's not
telling you
kind of normal stories it's not saying
you know when you go to work tomorrow uh
you might want to think about
cleaning your desk it's saying you know
uh you know there's a deer in a tree
and uh but the deer has wings and
um i i don't know why the deer is right
then suddenly i go up to the deer to
talk to it and it flies off
um and people don't seem to uh
don't seem to kind of recognize how
completely peculiar it is
that to continue watching this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas